hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the park my heart and
mind I always return to Atlantic Island
Park it's the park this game that came
out a while ago that I had attended plan
I'm about to be interrupted again so
here we go
where's mr. bear I haven't seen mr. bear
Kellum
[Music]
stay in the car go and ask information
oh oh okay so basically I intended to
play this game a while ago but it's one
of those things that got away from me
and it's a narrative experience and even
the preview said that it's hey make your
way to the carpark I have a bad habit of
interrupting absolutely everyone okay
press this woo I think I'll examine that
nope yeah we was born the day this place
open this is his favorite place in the
world
uh-huh alrighty then so you got him here
too late and you're failing as a parent
apparently can I not examine that could
I do something there we go hello hi oh
hello hi okay
hey Lorraine Lorraine
don't blame yourself Laurie
people lose things all the time take a
deep breath think about the last place
you saw your sons teddy bear hey stop
I think your boy just ran into the park
I'll unlock the gates for you um I'm
calling weird on this one
hi I didn't talk to you about a teddy
bear and I believe we're not in the time
zone that has cellphones so how would
you have known I didn't text you also
you think my son just ran in you're not
a hundred percent sure okay
don't mind me as I wander around oh it's
press x to jason this time except it's
right-click - Calum Calum I told you to
wait in the car Oh or here over here
isn't the car you seem to misunderstand
my basic intention
Calem ware oh I see him oh my god no how
about no something special about the
entrance to an amusement park okay a
line drawn between the real world and
the world of whimsy within mmm on this
side the apathy of our everyday lives
and on the other anything we might dad a
dream overpriced food Calum ran back
inside okay what yeah I also have
another question because if it was
really closing right as of the now whoa
it's a Reaper invasion holy [ __ ] whoa ah
I thought something was a little
kerfuffled around here I had a sneaking
suspicion that there was an overwhelming
load of bad
ah good oh great
Oh wunderbar oh that's good oh that's
good oh man
okay sorry I had to check the time Oh
God
the park what happened here I'm guessing
it God abandoned and it is now
horrifying and I'm pretty sure I'm going
towards the ferris wheel because
whenever they put something in the
distance in one of these games it's
usually the final destination lost here
it doesn't seem that easy there is
exactly one roller coaster a NOC code on
and then a tunnel of tails but first off
it looks like it's the house of horrors
so Caleb back here right now
Calum I'll buy another teddy bear who's
at the house of the room okay Calum
Calum don't go into the house of horrors
that's exactly where I didn't want to go
alright fine then don't hide from me
cows don't hide from me even though I
saw exactly where you went
I can't go in here alright so time to
skedaddle I suppose I doubt I'm gonna be
able to go that way or I dug aim wants
me to go that oh that's nice oh that's
nice oh that's real reassuring oh that's
one of those things that I enjoy very
much no way to see exacto kadam where
did you go
we're Carrie Killian is Satan's [ __ ]
I completely agree whoever the hell that
is and was come back here right now
ah yeah catch you kids oh oh I thought
you were like jumping you mean catch as
in a game of tag where'd you go okay I'm
on the way I don't know if I was
supposed to stop in there but apparently
not
to carry on this bizarre adventure oh
hello is that one of them moves anima
trauma is that a mascot does he that
blood on it hello Shu I think this
belongs to Cal my god
it probably do but also I'm more worried
about whatever the hell's going on here
each other chipmunk huh just a drunk guy
in a suit Chad the chipmunk worst in
class Chad can't even seem to pass Jack
gets angry likes to fight chad is beaten
every night Chad will have a dead-end
job Chad will die a useless slob what a
lovely poem and what a lovely
blood-stained squirrel mommy
okay this about
do you hear that someone targeted me
purchase land on Solomon island for a
pittance a my dad whatever old Artie
Henderson did to the locals just mention
of his name and people slamming doors
and locking shutters from the moment I
arrived on the island
my lawyers had arranged everything in
advance but the Realtors still had to
come and deliver the keys to me
personally he took it upon himself to
offer me another warning I don't know
why you're planning to do with this
bland mr. winter but the soil here is
bitter with a curse carried from the old
country old man Henderson he did
terrible dark sayings the land remembers
sir I dismissed him shortly afterwards
mostly amused by his pathetic attempts
at warning me off the grave vision for
this place and the will to see that
vision through to the very end
Atlantic Island Park the name is perfect
and I cannot imagine being anything else
this is a start of something amazing
well glad to know that I'm gonna find
out about the history of this but I want
to know who is whispering
horrible things in my ear was that you
Chad is that you you pathetic lump Oh
okay someone is whispering crazy
ramblings into the intercom
lovely to know all right I'm not playing
anymore Talan I wasn't playing to begin
with Callum hello where uh-huh come on
sweetie
Callum stay where you are Callum Callum
come on what have I told you about
getting on strange swans where are you I
know where you are you're right over
there
I don't wanna I don't want to go on the
tunnel of tales the tunnel of tales
sounds like bad alright fine I'll go on
the tunnel the tales let me on let me on
please please okay there we go ride Swan
I don't know what if this was the first
thing that I was supposed to Oh oh this
isn't gonna be fun well this is gonna be
one of those not fun things pretty much
like everything else
uh-huh can I look
oh I can look oh it's one of those
viewing rides I just can't look behind
me why did you go
so um I can tell him no mo great forest
they lived a poor woodcutter his wife
and his two children and then he
murdered them all named Hansel and a
girl named Gretel the gnarly thought
they were very poor and had very little
to bite or sup huh
what will become of us the woodcutter
asked his wife one night I tell you what
husband we will take the children into
the thickest part of the forest tomorrow
and abandon them there well no my wife
cannot do that ah said the man then we
will all fall starve you fool
ah oh yeah you fool why not think of
murder their parents talking and Gretel
began to weep no no no why do not fret
Gretel Hansel said he crept out of the
hut and gathered white stones from the
ground to fill his pockets uh-huh Oh a
mines gonna be looking at this oh yes
very nice artwork ya file the plans of
your parents to murder you the
woodcutter needs the children into the
forest how persuasive is that wife their
mother gives them a slice of bread and
warns them that they will get no more
food that day what a generous mother
clever hunt leaves a trail of white
stones behind them as they pass what a
story
when their father leaves them the
children wait a while then follow the
trail back to their parents house uh-huh
battle fort their murderous intent
they'll be so happy receiving a thorough
scolding from their parents for getting
lost in the woods the children are sent
to bed without any supper well she did
warn them try to sneak out and collect
more white stones but found out a door
was locked
tomorrow I will take them into the woods
myself the wife told the woodcutter yeah
if you can't do it right
murder your children yourself then
mother gave them a slice of bread and
led them deep into the forest once again
okay why Carolyn pencil broke his bread
into pieces and left a trail of
breadcrumbs to lead them safely home
but hungry eye birds snatched up the
breadcrumbs and his trail was destroyed
uh-huh now you have no food and no plan
what are you gonna do now clever a
little more and unable to find the trail
home the children wandered in the forest
for three days okay okay the children
stumbled into a clearing with an
exceedingly strange house its walls were
made of gingerbread and its windows were
panes of clear sugar I think I know how
this goes desperately hungry run forward
I began to nibble on the walls the end
what a happy story that was my house
it's kind of your fault lady for having
your candy house knowledge into the
south sniffing the air and peering
around cloudy eyes oh you dear children
who brought you here just come in and
stay with me no harm will come to you in
Hansel and Gretel stayed back for the
old woman reminded them of their cruel
mother probably a good call come
children don't be afraid I have
something for you it's probably better
than your previous situation enormous
lollipops oh the children took them and
began to eat you see
nothing to fear here come inside the old
woman urged and the children still
licking their sweets followed
[Music]
okay yeah that's what I imagined would
happen into a cage and put Gretel to
work sweeping and cleaning her I guess
in the grand scheme of things I'll make
a good mouthful the old witch told
Gretel Pal is gonna say she's fattened
up I shall feast upon him I've gotta say
it better than starving to death in the
woods but I guess it took a turn for the
worst but then again I do know the story
of Hansel and Gretel refused to eat
fearing the day that which would eat it
the witch for her part grew impatient
today I will cook and eat your brother
Gretel
climb inside and light the oven but
Gretel pretended not to understand uh I
do not know how where is the opening
fool the old witch said the opening is
here and she would to show Gretel
seizing her courage brave Gretel gave
the winch a shove an old chrome tumble
fort into the oven new little slid a
large iron bolt over the door to the
oven
Gretel freed her brother Hansel and
together they lit a fire beneath the
oven mm-hmm and though she screamed and
begged the children sat by the oven
until her screams had stilt I know which
was cooked uh-huh okay and then they
lived happily ever and can't survive on
sweets they divided up the body of the
old witch and ate her huh oh yeah I
remember the story ending whoa
so that's how I remember it ending at
all also why did I need to go through a
whole tale of Hansel and Gretel
[Music]
whoa Wow
did that thing look at me throughout
that story cuz that's not cool that
almost made that whole story worth it
holy [ __ ] that was creepy
okay rides over forget my son my life
has changed I don't need anybody or
anything to tell me what to do okay mom
stay where you are
wherever the hell you went hope you
didn't get any ideas from that thing
would you say stop hiding Calum which
way which way why are you whispering and
why can I hear you if you're whispering
no Calum yes Gretel
I used to read it to Calum when the
electricity was shut off uh-huh
yeah just poor children the whole world
against them the forest the birds feel
which even their own parents yeah no
joke I used to imagine that Calum and I
were the kids in that story not mother
and son but brother and sister hand in
hand against the unkind world we were
always hungry looking for our own house
made of candy looking for the sweetness
that could take the pain away
hunger leads people to desperate
terrible places where the tree branches
reach like claws
well that's horrific Alise ad man what
the hell happened in your life I don't
do I even want to know hello Calum so
what I'm gonna do is I'm I will follow
the trail am i following it the right
way I thought you were whispering the
other way
over over somewhere what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go back to the house of
horrors because I imagine that I might
have missed over something and I don't
want to miss too much in this game too
dark I'm not going in there without a
flash oh okay oh is that how we're gonna
do that so I will be back when I get
back to where I was put to be okay so
we're back on the right track rip me for
trying to actually go back and get some
spooks although that that Swan head was
pretty dang creepy like it wasn't like
scary horror jump scare scary it was
like that legitimate creep that you feel
crawling up your spine just like whoa
that shouldn't be happening and that's
that's what I like about woo another
accident this place what do you mean
another accident what are you talking
about are you are you in there oh the
blood oh that kind of accident the one
where there is the dead
[Music]
we're despite the constant interruptions
to work Atlanta Guilin Park will be
opening on time the governor is booked
to cut the ribbon so the only real
question is whether we will have any
customers I'm not really worried the
true customers will come out of simple
curiosity I deduced what was needed from
the banned writings of Archie Henderson
it's astonishing to think that a
resonance of positive emotions can be
used to feel such a process henderson
himself chose to use negative and that
caused some of the taint that still
lingers in this place I will not make
his mistakes very soon I will know if
this has been all for nothing so yeah
you'll won't make his mistakes you being
an entrepreneurial park owner him who
sounds like he did human sacrifices
there's not much difference between the
two but I'm glad you can discern the
different avenues to take about it so
what is that the teddy bear that I lost
also knife and eye and blood on seat
those are questions those aren't
statements those are questions as to why
that is that way that it is mommy needs
to see you come
hey maybe mommy's gonna give this up
I mean I don't want to say that I money
more dedicated than the story of Hansel
and Gretel so maybe I should just call
this one a day and cut my losses the
loss is being my son well I guess I'll
be a little more brave
Hey who's down rocks
sack of [ __ ] think you can mess with me
with some simple rock egde gonna take a
love
meant to dissuade whoo is it tilt awhirl
that's the octopus thing but it looks
like it has a goblin head or sanic I'm
not sure which one oh I want to go for a
ride
also the layout of this park is not very
good I will readily admit that things
aren't exactly easy to get to and get
back from us to make the blood run to my
head make me dizzy ok cool guy just
snapped those four ball right we were
waiting for our turn on the ride Frank
me and the boys has fell in the chipmunk
suit is making a nice carving while
people took photographs Laurence wanted
to go over to him but I've always been a
bit wary of those suits they give me the
creeps it's silly I know
anyway the chipmunk man he was carving
and picking away at the ice and at first
we thought he was making some animal
like a tiger line but it's more as more
ice fell away when you first looked it
was like a human face smiling out of the
block of ice but the more you looked at
it the more you saw that there was
something not quite right about the
proportions something unnatural that
made your heart begin to beat a little
bit faster like you were prey and that
thing in the ice was the hunter but then
these teenagers walked up and wanted
them made a face at the carving and said
something rude to the guy in the
chipmunk suit and then well he went
berserk for a few moments who was chaos
everyone was running away from the guy
who had one of the teenagers on the
ground and he was stabbed stabbed
stabbing with the ice pick and whoa jeez
Frank and I had the kids and we were
dragging them away as fast as we could
and the last thing I saw before Frank
dragged me away was the eyeball of one
of those poor kids had landed on the ice
sculpture making them horrible grater
looked more or less alive yeah I'm sure
it landed in exactly the right spot for
an eyeball to make it look alive also
why was he ice carving in a chipmunk
suit that seems like unnecessarily harsh
okay alright Callum thanks for being
such a good boy and helping me and such
are you on the ride be on the ride
mommy needs to see you come hello ah
ride octo Tron why not let's increase
the speed why not we do little more a
little more
come on or we got more than that oh I
see the dial of that we got more it
looks good I think that's apt to mine
Oh dangit Dinges ting and damn it I
thought I was gonna be able to do more
yeah okay there we go
boink let's get on I'm sure this will go
great for me also why did I decide to
get on a ride when I was looking for my
son
Oh No someone's messing with the
controls it's exactly my nightmare oh I
think I saw someone in the booth over
there I don't know why I tilted my head
not like I would be able to see it
I guess ripped whoa boy whoa boy
hi I see you in there Zack Calum Calum
oh boy yeah we're going for another pass
oh dang it didn't see it that time hello
Oh oh Jesus
hey how did I miss that holy [ __ ] was
that there before or did that just pop
up all jump scary like was I supposed to
see that
okay why did you go Callum come ok
Callum who examine Polaroid huh oh I
remember this oh you're making quite a
face there and he looks so eager to be
there why is this picture the way that
it is alright
you sounded like it was a fond of memory
but it didn't seem that way this way ok
I got you now sir he hides and thoughts
treachery that lashes like a whip and
scars our insights the first time I saw
Callum my thoughts betrayed me I looked
down at this wrinkled red balling thing
and I thought is that it we build our
world from expectations and the world
that I had built for Callum was no
different he was so real so there and so
far from my expectations he shattered as
they fell in pieces that one treacherous
thought became a new foundation all of
the love that we shared oh the warmth
and goodness that followed built on a
single traitorous thought I don't know
that's how that works maybe that's what
you tell yourself I thought working in
the park for the summer would be a lot
of fun but the end of the season really
drags there aren't that many tourists
around here and so most of the staff
spend their days standing around
gossiping most of that gossip is about
Chad I mean Steve see even I'm starting
to call him Chad and I went to school
with the guy that goddamn suit in the
beginning it was a laugh Steve the local
lush is Chad the chipmunk child friendly
mascot landok Island Park lock up your
daughters and all that but the more he
wears a suit the weirder Steve's getting
at first it was little things like
refusing him to change out of the suited
working taking it home with him every
day but then I saw him at Susie's diner
still wearing it and it wasn't even a
workday
some of the staff complained to park
management about the smell and I saw him
walking and talking
with min or mr. winter one day but
nothing seems to have changed the suit
still smells like a carcass whenever
Steve walked by and apparently Steve was
picked up some new skills since the time
I saw him puking up in the gutter
outside the oil station because he sure
as hell can carve a mean ice sculpture
those shapes make he makes in the ice
though they give me the creeps Steve
tombe came by the booth today and he
just hung around for a while I couldn't
really tell because of the suit but it
seemed like he was just staring at me
sizing me up I [ __ ] me whatever he
was doing I asked him what he wanted and
he just stood there not saying anything
eventually I called my supervisor and
when it came by Chad Steve wandered off
my supervisor told me to put everything
in writing so here it is also I quit I
don't want to see that Chipmunks who
never again okay hi oh you're gonna give
me a hooah you're still in there come
back come back come on scare me again
come on do it I'm right here I still see
you in there I know you're in there
camphor May I'm coming in there coming
in okay fine Callum stay where you are
yeah he's not gonna do that okay will do
will do buddy boo oooh that's a lovely
looking something-or-other oh is that
the octo tron huh okay where are we
headed back to oh the bumper cars who's
at the nest adventure that we're gonna
be riding on do I have enough time for
that I'm not 100% sure but I think I
might be running out of time for this
episode constant crashes and eighties
music I guess it floats someone's boat
yeah mine don't knock it
but that's all the time that I got for
this episode so I'm gonna pick this up
in another one real soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to another episode of this
coming real soon because walnut packs
this weekend we're gonna get through
this whole story so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye